[Music]
cloud spanner is a fully managed
relational database from google cloud
that combines the structure of a
relational database with the horizontal
scalability offered by non-relational
databases
spanner offers unlimited scale strong
consistency and up to five nines
availability so you can build resilient
scalable applications that transform
your business while lowering your total
cost of ownership
with spanner you get a fully managed
database so you can focus on developing
your application there are no scheduled
downtime windows
schema changes are done online without
blocking database access and when you're
ready it's simple to scale both reads
and writes without any limits
spanner is suited for any use case where
you want easy scalability without losing
consistency
spanner is trusted by customers across
industries such as finance retail
healthcare and gaming
cloud spanner is excited to introduce a
free trial instance to help you become
familiar with spanner and its
capabilities at zero cost
the cloud spanner free trial instance
gives you access to a spanner instance
with 10 gigabytes of storage capacity
for 90 days
this instance is meant for learning
purposes to help you become familiar
with spanner
if you are already a google cloud user
with an active google cloud billing
account you are ready to create your
free trial instance
otherwise you can create a new google
cloud billing account that gives you
access to the spanner free trial
instance as well as 300 in credits to
use on all google cloud products to set
up the free trial instance all you need
is an existing google cloud project
if you don't have a project create one
billing must be enabled in your
organization while the project requires
billing information there are no charges
for using this instance for 90 days
until you upgrade
when your project is set up navigate to
cloud spanner in the cloud console and
click to create a spanner free trial
instance
once your free trial instance is running
you can get started exploring spanner
we provide a walkthrough for setting up
a sample finance database using either
the default google sql dialect or the
new postgresql dialect
spanner gives you the flexibility to use
ansi compliant google sql or a
postgresql interface that supports the
popular postgresql engine
allowing you to use existing skills and
expertise to manage your data you can
also bring your own schema and test how
it will work on spanner
to get started with an example finance
database simply click the learn button
in the console
this will open up instructions to get
the sample database and workload running
using cloud shell
the init command will download the
required binaries and create the
database
the first tutorial is about exploring
the schema that is created within cloud
console
the second tutorial then allows you to
run a workload against the database that
was created
then you can run queries on the data
that was generated
it has never been easier to try out
cloud spanner
with the free trial you have 90 days to
try out spanner at no cost using a free
instance you can even build a fully free
application on google cloud by using
cloud spanner free trial along with the
free tier offered by other products such
as compute engine or bigquery
you can upgrade your free trial instance
to a paid instance at any time without
any downtime
then you can continue with your proof of
concept of building your application
with the full benefits that spanner
provides such as scaling and
multi-regional configurations
so go ahead and create a cloud spanner
free trial instance today
[Music]
you